el teléfono de este hombre no para de
sonar en qué parte de la ciudad está
usted al otro lado de la línea personas
le ruegan que vaya a buscarlos
alexei para believe acude regularmente a
cediera daniel para evacuar a los
civiles una ciudad que está bajo el
intenso fuego de las fuerzas rusas que
marchen
tengan cuidado con los grandes
los cracks son cohetes que han estado
disparando contra los ucranianos desde
el comienzo de la guerra alexei es
taxista pero ha optado por transportar a
la gente gratuitamente mientras dure la
guerra
no tenemos que tomar las armas ni
unirnos a la defensa del territorio hay
otras formas de ayudar
aquí están las personas que llevarán y
pro la ciudad más segura al oeste
decidió vender su coche para comprar
esta furgoneta aunque no es tan cómoda
es como un milagro para sus pasajeros
y pensaba que estaría bien aquí pero no
es así en absoluto lo siento es muy
aterrador putin strokes
otros los residentes abrazan
calurosamente a su héroe una especie de
ángel de la guarda llamado a la acción
en medio del peligro
separado a mí esta es la ciudad más
apartada del este del país que sigue
bajo control ucraniano es un objetivo
constante para los invasores y las
autoridades quieren que todos los
civiles se vayan en la furgoneta el
alivio que sienten estos dos hombres es
palpable han recuperado la esperanza y
perpetuo en el primero iraní pro y
después ya veré a dónde me lleva el
destino
el taxista le da combustible a esta
mujer porque no queda más en la
gasolinera encendieran es que ya no hay
agua en los grifos sino que la
distribuyen los bomberos los habitantes
de la ciudad no tienen acceso al gas ni
a la electricidad desde el comienzo de
la guerra